hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong i am mark ellis
joined as always by jack with coley
jaclyn there is some swindling going on
on tinder and i want to talk about it
but unfortunately that's not what we're
here to discuss today
no but i will say this i have not
watched the tinder swindler netflix
documentary but i have watched the id
uh episode
on because id
uh discovery network is where all of the
good docs happen before they go to
netflix and elsewhere because those guys
are on the ground floor
oh okay yeah all right so you you might
actually be ahead of me in some in some
regard when it comes to these big
documentaries that i just think i just
discovered for everybody else no they're
quick and dirty tiger king quick and
dirty but you you get the points you get
to get in there
the netflix ones are better
we are here to talk about something that
i guess got in on the ground four if you
wanted to way back in 1965
with a novel by a young man named
herbert and then that went on to be a
1984 film directed by none other than
david lynch and again in 2021 at least
the first half directed by denny
villeneuve and that would be
dune the epic about sand and spice the
1984 david lynch version is 43
rotten on the tomato meter 65 audience
course at least it's fresh there and the
2021 film 83 certified fresh and with
the audience it is all the way up to 90
so we're gonna be talking about all
things dune both versions of the film
we're going to be covering here today
and getting deep with the war is going
to be the host of the big hit show
podcast and the upcoming book most
triumphant story of keanu reeves
filmography alex papademis is about to
join us here jacqueline this is so
exciting because you came across doing
long before i did but we talked about it
we were hyped when the movie was coming
out it got some oscar nods but also
like there's no real way to give a
synopsis to dune without taking the
amount of time that the movie takes to
watch right
yeah um it's it's space it's sand it's
worms and
spice and uh everything nice with
timothy chalamet and
david lynch that's why you love it
it's one of the reasons why i love it i
i will say that yeah but yeah i mean
you're you're also a big david lynch now
david lynch let's just clear the record
right here was never really in the
running to direct return of the jedi
because he didn't want to do it but
there was a meeting george lucas asked
him if he would be interested in return
of the jedi said no to that next year
dune comes out so we're going to be
talking about the 84 dune and dannyville
news first half of dune that i just got
to watch both these this week and so a
whole lot of excitement here it's a
story of destiny and we'll leave it at
that but as we shortchange the synopsis
we are going to remind you all that we
are going to be talking spoilers of
plenty for both versions and maybe we'll
get into some novel spoilers too but
nothing too deep there because reading
is a lot harder than watching a movie
what is great is when we get to hear tim
ryan our expert review curation manager
here at rotten tomatoes tell us what the
critics were saying at the time of the
release of 84 and the release of last
year's 2021 version of dune tim the
floor is yours
[Music]
frank herbert's dune has often been
described as an unfilmable book but that
hasn't dissuaded filmmakers from taking
a crack at it on today's podcast we're
discussing david lynch's 1984 version
which critics largely found to be
visually striking but narratively
muddled and denny villeneuve's 2021
version which critics largely found to
be visually striking and substantially
more narratively coherent the 1984 dune
is rotten at 43 with 65 reviews and it
has a 65 audience score the 2021 dune is
certified fresh at 83 with 447 reviews
and has a 90 audience score and just for
the record hodorowski's dune a
documentary that chronicles alejandra
hodorowski's frustratingly futile
attempt to adapt dune is certified fresh
at 98 with 121 reviews so what did the
critics have to say let's start with the
1984 version in a rotten review janet
maslin of the new york times wrote
several of the characters in dune are
psychic which puts them in the unique
position of being able to understand
what goes on in the movie however in a
fresh review kirk ellis of the hollywood
reporter wrote dune is not the
masterpiece its adherents have hoped for
but neither is it the disaster its
detractors have claimed now for the 2021
version in a fresh review k austin
collins of rolling stone wrote
villanov's dune is a thick loud well-fed
spectacle of a movie towering over the
people in it with a brooding sense of
intention even in its quieter moments
even when wrestling through the herbert
novel's wide-ranging learned quirky
mysticism however in a rotten review joe
morgenstern the wall street journal
wrote the plot machinery grinds to a
halt as if clogged with sand and the
well-earned welcome wears out
so that's the dune cinematic universe
let's kick it back to jacqueline and
mark who have worm signed the likes of
which even god has never seen back to
you folks
i mean
sand worms in fact they're prominently
into this movie and uh there's another
film that it reminded me of that
features the sand worm so jaclyn we're
gonna talk about all this stuff and see
whatever else what other can of worms we
can open with alex papadamis right on
the other side of this let's get into
movie talk
and as promised now we are welcoming the
star of the big hit show podcast and
dropping april 28th is the author of
most triumphant a look back at all of
the hits and some misses of keanu reeves
film career the one the only alex
pompadamus joining us here alex hello
sir thank you so much for having me um
i'm not the star of the big hit show
though i have to say it's the tape is
the star of the big hit show and the
story is the star of the big hit show i
just have to say that because i'm not
that implies like a level of singing and
dancing that i'm not ready to take
like a dean martin kind of quality that
like i would like to say that i
possessed but i don't know the star of
our show but no no i am just the host
i'm just the conduit to the information
i'm sorry to correct you as our very
very beginning of our relationship no
that's a that's a very humble way to
come on our show but we are thrilled to
have you and not just because i want to
talk about both dune movies and and
jacqueline and i are coming at dune from
very different angles just as far as
when it entered our
our airspace i guess i should say so
before i ask you if the tomato meter is
right or wrong with either the 84 or the
2021 dune when did you first stumble
across this dune mythology was it the
novel was it one of the films
it was all right so i was born in 1977
in 1984 i was do the math seven years
old um so the thing about the 1984 dune
which maybe people who experience it now
for the first time don't really
necessarily get
about it is that it went through the
blockbuster pipe along with all of those
other things everybody thought this was
going to be another star wars and so
this was marketed to kids to
seven-year-olds like me there was a toy
line uh from ljn like the sort of star
wars figures and everything and there
were uh so my first dune experience was
the
dune story book shout out to adapter
joan duvinge
uh it's like a hardback book for kids
but it has the entire story of the movie
and a lot of like stills from the movie
and they did this a lot like you would
get this from your scholastic book order
or whatever and like everybody in your
class would be spoiled on return of the
jedi like months ahead of time because
they didn't have their things kind of
lined up and everything so
that was how i learned about it and i
just assumed that this was meant for me
as all things that were marketed in that
way were meant for me and then of course
you watched this movie and
it was traumatizing in kind of the best
way and it really stuck with me and i
think that was where all of that
mythology just of the the guild
navigators mutating and all of those
things
really made an impression on me and then
years later i became a fan of it almost
in a different way because i became a
huge david lynch fan in the interim so
in like
1992-1 whatever
watched it again a bunch of times as an
obsessive lynch head and saw everything
that was going on with that movie that
felt like david lynch to me and then i
became a fan of it
in a different way so i kind of had
those first two experiences and you
could not have told me i was very
surprised to learn that it was a bomb
the first time because i was like this
is an amazing uh space epic that i that
i love as a it's seven eight-year-old
yeah the novel came out in 65 and so and
so you had all this war that was built
into uh this sort of the public
consciousness and i think that it's
regarded as the best-selling sci-fi
novel of all time
as well and and so alex the the public
wants to know needs this information
when you look at the tomato meter for
due 1984
it's 43
rotten so let's start with that one is
rotten tomatoes wrong with that score
i'm gonna say that score is not
surprising but personally i disagree
with it it is uh you know if it's if it
was just me that score would be much
higher that was so diplomatic yeah well
the audience is 65 and so i think the
audience maybe favors this movie maybe
for some of those childhood reasons that
you do why in your mind i guess is the
84 one a a fresh movie it sounds like is
it just the the nostalgia of it or when
you go back and watch it is the winchian
elements that you've come to love in
other movies what stands out to you
about that 84 dune i think i mean and i
actually feel this way about
both of them i feel this way about the
84 one and the 2021 one that these are
both very specific
directorial signatures on
uh an attempt to make dune
into a blockbuster movie right so
they're clearly they're they're both
trying to take this very sort of
voluminous and confusing like if you
read the original novel like that is a
dense book like it is it is a heavy
dense book with a lot of story and a lot
of backstory and they are try both
trying to turn this into something that
feels like a fun like popcorn space
movie like in the star wars vein in some
way in some way or another while kind of
nodding to those kind of philosophical
aspects of it that exist
i love how much even though i think
lynch considers it a failure i love how
much he was able to put his stamp on
this project despite sort of what the
intention was which was to create like
the next star wars basically somebody
hired somebody wanted to create the next
star wars out of dune and they gave it
to david lynch which made sense for a
number of reasons at the time which we
could maybe talk about but like you know
that he was there was a moment when he
seemed to be pivoting towards like a you
know a different career than he ended up
with
and so i love how much it feels like
david lynch unleashed with this 40
million dollar budget now you can see
why he doesn't like it and why he's
unhappy with it and why he thinks it's
the one movie where he kind of sold out
and they there was a lot of stuff that
was foisted on him uh in the edit he
turned in a three-hour movie it's two
hours you know it was rewritten in the
editing room all of that i see all of
those flaws but
the more i watch it the more i see
somebody who just you can't you know you
sort of it's like david lynch is like
the ingredient that you put in the stew
that sort of it's like it's gonna taste
like david lynch it's gonna turn into a
david lynch stew no matter what and so
there's so much of his kind of spirit in
there and so much of his invention that
i have a real affection for it that i
don't think is really about nostalgia
because i think when i was a kid it kind
of like just messed me up watching it
like i was like i don't know what this
is so i mean maybe it's a nostalgia for
like late adolescence for being like 14
instead of being eight i mean jacqueline
i imagine for a kid watching this movie
it is like a like a sniff of spice to
the skull and you're just like like your
whole world opens up and the thing that
i want because i'm also with alex here i
think that the tomato meter is way too
low for the 84 dune and i watched this
after i saw 2021's version i really
really had fun with this movie because i
didn't know if i was gonna get something
that felt very over the top like cheesy
like a flash gordon or something that
that did feel more authentic and what i
got was like an engaging sci-fi story it
gets very
dull is the wrong word but but it gets
very slow at points
but the performances in this movie were
great and i loved as i'm watching the
opening credits i see
and it reminded me that i knew this
information at some point the music done
by toto
and brian eno doing the the prophecy
score i'm like oh you're speaking my
language now i'm in see so this is
what's so crazy about
dune is i just so wonder
what david lynch's dune could have been
with the technology that is available
now
because the problem with that i have
with dune is the same problem that they
had when they decided to make this the
technology of movie making at the time
was not something that could in any way
match the vision of what frank put in
the novel
and it's just silly so i think i saw
dune
late later not this late but like later
it was definitely an encore watch i
definitely recall the like promos
because if folks remember back in the
day if you watched linear premium
television they didn't have commercials
so the only thing they put in between
there were these little mini commercials
for the movies that were coming out on
the platform and i remember very
distinctly watching the promo for dune
which then means that i probably watched
dune because i also like still remember
the promo for heathers which is where i
watched that movie for the first time so
i know i watched it at that time and i
didn't care i just remember lots of sand
and i remember
you know kyle mclaughlin who i thought
was kind of dreamy at the time and he
was he's very dreamy at the time still
um still is and um after sex and city
though we don't like him as much um
just so you know he was very bad in that
show in the sense of like we hated his
character anyway
so i just i just didn't think it was
great and then when i revisited it
previously recently before this new one
was about to come out i was just like i
can't
i can't with the bad cgi i can't with
like stings in a different movie i like
the movie that he's in but he's in a
different movie the harkness character
just some of the things that they did it
is a very lynchian tale i'm not gonna
pretend that that's true but there's
just there's so many limitations on the
storytelling and at times it's just
laughable and so all of the great things
that it does do well
are just like held down and i think it's
this what it is it was a 40 million
dollar movie and so it has these big
movie sentiments but it's in so many
ways shot like the toxic avenger and i
just wish we would have just gotten the
toxic avenger version of dune like just
make it
like don't pretend it feels like a
student movie so just make the student
movie version of dune let it cheese let
it camp give me the john waters dune i
would have enjoyed it more alex do you
agree with that that maybe you just lean
into what it was of the time and and
don't try to be something that was ahead
of its time which was where we could
have gotten all this great cgi that we
see in the 2021 version but we just you
know it's a quote marty mcfly we just
weren't ready for that yet right the
technology wasn't there i want to say
that i would love to see the john waters
dune i don't want to say i don't want to
be in in any way disagreeing with that
sentiment because i want i'm in favor of
giving john waters most properties uh if
he wants
alex i have a question for you real
quick at this ask me why the cgi and
sinbad and the 7cs is better than the
cgi and dune tell me why and that was
claymation the technology was there
yeah it's like trying to do it maybe
trying to do less i mean i will say that
like i enjoy this because of the
practical effects in some way i like the
you know all of these the kind of the
monsters and the way that the sand worm
is very clear there's a guy's arm in
there you can just kind of it just has
that feeling about it i mean it is you
do feel like you can see the budget
running out as things are happening you
know that they're running through that
40 million dollars and that maybe 40
million dollars was not enough and that
you know at some point uh you know yeah
i guess i just appreciate that about it
because it feels like this it like all
of it it just feels like an expansion
it's like if eraserhead had a 40 million
dollar budget and it just feels like
what david lynch would do with that
um and so that kind of you know i mean
maybe i'm just a stan maybe that's just
you know that is the bottom line here
that i'm like he you know because i
don't think i don't even think that he
meant to do this i don't think he would
agree with me i think this is the one
movie he doesn't this is the one movie
he doesn't like to talk about yeah i've
seen in interviews that the the david
lynch regrets how it came out because he
did feel like he was made in the editing
room without him and it was not the cut
that he would have approved he wanted a
longer film too because he wanted his
name taken off of it yeah his name take
it off of it so yeah well he took his
name off he had the long version the tv
version which he has a bunch of scenes
just
they wanted to make it 176 minutes they
just stuck a bunch of stuff back in
there apparently it doesn't really exist
in any form that he'd be happy with like
they've offered him the chance to do a
director's cut on it and he's like nah i
don't want to i don't want to revisit it
because i guess he didn't get to shoot
it the way that he wanted to and they
had to shoot all this extra stuff and
like all that apparently all the
narration the parts where it's like you
know you just sort of there's a shot a
static shot of somebody's face and then
they're like thinking in their head you
know like duke leto never has a second
cup of coffee at home that's all like uh
something that he you know was was
forced to do
right because of they need to get all
this exposition in there because they're
terrified that it won't make sense to
people that's the main problem with it
is it's like larded with all of this
information up front that they want you
to get
they want you to know everything going
in they don't want you to be confused
and i think part of the nuev movie
that's better is that like they you know
directors are able to trust audiences a
little more and also they're expecting
people to have read about it ahead of
time so they're not going to be walking
and completely lost and so the first 40
minutes of dune is like teaching you how
to watch dune in the lynch version and
it's very it's you know very here's
here's what all these factions are about
and you know it's a lot of information
thrown at you but see as an audience
member i am wait like okay i'm a
reasonably intelligent human like out on
the street and i got some book smarts
i'm a [ __ ] sometimes when it comes to
watching movies especially getting
inundated with all this mythology so i
it was like playing catch up watching
because i saw the 2021 version first and
so by the time i came to david lynch's
dune i i felt pretty versed and i felt
like oh i can keep up with this and i
will defend to my dying breath how cool
the armor looks in the 84 one when the
during the combat scenes that it looked
cool to me especially in 1984 i imagine
that's like something that i would
immediately run out of the theater and
me and my brother would be fighting each
other with pillows
robots dude oh come on worse they looked
worse
what's the scene for you alex that you
say this 1984 like this is why i can
still enjoy and revisit this can you
boil it down to to a scene that really
stands out to you from that first movie
yeah i mean there's a lot but i will
give it to
the first
big sort of set piece scene where the uh
the guild navigator which is this uh it
i guess used to be a guy and has morphed
into a giant worm who floats in a tank
of space drugs all the time and that
gives him the power to fold space and
sort of move uh you know arm armadas of
spaceships from one side of the galaxy
to the other and
uh one of these creatures shows up with
his entourage to have an audience and
kind of give the emperor of the galaxy a
hard time
and
it
sort of pulls into this uh big sort of
throne room in what looks like a giant
train it's a very lynchian sort of
object it looks like the teapot from
twin peaks the return it looks like a
train car with like steam coming out of
it it's just like it's it's one of those
things this is what i'm talking about
that like he manages to get like the
types of things that he just loves to
shoot for whatever reason for whatever
kind of like unexplained
david lynch aesthetic preference
and then it opens up and it's this like
really gnarly sort of puppet thing with
a kind of like i'm just gonna say it's
kind of a vaginal mouth that opens and
breathes and talks you know and it's a
very kind of weird david lynch dream
image it looks like that you know if you
if you know eraser head it kind of looks
like the baby from a racer head like
he's got all of these he has kinks and
he keeps hitting them in movie after
movie
and there's a lot of exposition in this
movie there's a lot of in this piece of
the movie there's a lot of things that
aren't explained but you do get the
sense of this vast galaxy and i
with a lot of
weird stuff going on that you are not
necessarily let in on and i am
enraptured every time when it's like the
guy's like there are many machines on ix
and i'm like i don't know what ix is i
don't know why that's significant but
like the like jose ferreira seems very
like upset about this like he's like oh
really like yeah yeah we have
from
just
yes
how was your journey
many machines
new machines
oh
yes
better than those on recess
you are transparent
i see
many things
i see plans within plans
i see two great houses
the trainees house are conan feuding
i see
you behind it as much as this movie is
like probably sort of you know
kept from being as great as it is by its
need to explain everything and by its
need to kind of lead the audience by the
hand
it's also so confusing and that feeling
of being confused like takes me back to
being a kid i guess in some ways and i
love that about it but it's just it's so
ominous and there's so much seriousness
but then there's also like all of the
weird production design that like his
sort of
uh which like the the knee version has a
little bit too with the guy with the
microphones you know those guys talking
to the you know because that's what i
like about the denim one two is i think
it takes in the lynch one as part of the
mythology a little bit like it makes it
part of the the lynch mythology but yeah
there's all those like strange
characters who show up and you know it's
just a
like sting holding a hairless cat like
come on a lot of good animals in this
movie a lot of good animals listen i'm
not mad about steaks
we get we we get uh
the house of tradies pug and then we get
a hairless cat and so we do get a little
bit of everything now those aren't even
i mean those are some of my favorite
parts of the movie jaclyn but it's also
just fun having eyes on this and the
2021 dennyville new version which will
bring in now somewhat is 83 percent
certified fresh on the tomato meter so a
markedly
you know
improvement from at least how critics
felt about the original and even higher
with the audience score it's a 90
audience course so if you're a fan of
dune whether it was 84 it was the novel
it seems like you were pretty pleased
with this new version and that was one
of the delights of going back to 84 for
me is seeing like the character of
gurney for instance you get to see josh
brolin but then i saw patrick stewart as
him and it is like oh this is some
really there's some good casting
matchups here now jacqueline if i give
you the character of paul and i say okay
it's kyle mclaughlin versus your boy
timothy chalamet i think i know which
way you're leaning but it's it's a hard
decision for you i'm willing to bet
actually okay
this is the problem kyle mclaughlin is
too old to play paula tradies and
timothy chalamet is too dainty
they kind of make a joke about it
like where um yeah momoa of all people
just kind of like give them a break work
it out senior freshman bully moment oh
my god it was so bad yeah i was reminded
of wart the animated character from
disney sword and the stone when i was
watching timothy chalamet because
i appreciated that about him that he is
just so
dainty he's just so thin and young
looking and that this is i mean this
whole movie is is basically it boils
down to this kid doesn't feel like he's
ready for their responsibilities but at
some point life is just going to saddle
you with it and you have to suck it up
and sort of live out your destiny even
if you don't feel prepared for it which
us watching it we're like this kid can't
take on the fate of the entire universe
but that's sort of the the point isn't
it is that you don't feel ready for this
and you just have to suck it up and just
do it so
for me
i i appreciated what what denny started
and i'm looking forward to what he
finishes sooner rather than later alex
are you with the tomato meter score for
the 2021 dune is rotten tomatoes wrong
or right with that 83
yeah sure i mean you know i think some
of the reception of the 2021 one is
born out of this
belief that the 1984 one it needs to be
remedied somehow by you know the doing
it right you know which is a very which
is a very kind of like modern sort of
superhero movie way of thinking about
things where it's like oh this one in
the past was a little corny and there
were some things wrong with it so we're
going to do we're going to do it right
and there's a certain like aesthetic
criteria that sort of constitutes doing
it right and part of it is just doing it
real big and like letting it you know
kind of breathe in a way that like it
does make it you know
more in the spirit of the novel feel
more epic you know that like he only
does the first half of the book and just
kind of cuts it off
like in a crazy way so that the big sort
of like climactic battle in the first
one is a knife fight which is kind of
great i sort of love that about it and
it like hits it it's you know it looks
amazing it's like i really feel like
that one is probably the 2021 is
probably the best
case scenario for a big
modern
blockbuster adaptation of this book that
just recedes further and further into
the past and like really kind of has to
be brought forward in a lot of ways
creatively so i think that
yeah i think it's you know it's
definitely it's definitely that i don't
buy that there was something wrong with
the 84 one and that part of you know i
think that's a lot of like what people
are excited about it's like oh finally
somebody like really did it but like i
feel like david lynch really did it too
in a david lynch way which again david
lynch would tell me that i'm wrong
loudly and and then not say anything
else
yeah jack what part of this though is i
i just think that maybe critics in 84
and i'm not trying to speak for them
might have looked at this movie and said
okay so the eraserhead guy is now doing
this beloved sci-fi novel i don't know
that he got the credibility as a
director that denny villeneuve got in
2021 when dune is coming out because
folks love this guy's movies already and
he's just seen as as this
modern-day auteur who whenever he's got
a property coming regardless what the
movie's about people want to go see it
because good chance is going to be
critically acclaimed in oscar sort of
conversations those are worlds you walk
in is that your feeling on 2021's dune
is that it lived up to the hype of a
denny villeneuve director
um
yes it definitely lives up to the hype
but i do think that there's a little bit
of correcting the record with david
lynch because what's interesting and
what you know alex sort of remind me of
he was one of the first directors to
sort of feel the brunt of an indie
director
going and doing a big budget thing and
the somewhat betrayal but what's
interesting is it wasn't like chloe zhao
doing the eternals
david lynch doing dune was like
gaspar noe doing
uh um doctor strange like it's very like
yeah you know and honestly the closer
thing to it is james gunn doing
guardians of the galaxy james gunn is a
troma
like very uh exploitation style director
and so him doing a like family-esque
friendly comedy movie uh about
superheroes is really a twist and that's
what lynch did and i think people
thought it was going to be like that and
i think if dune could have had the
technology to support what it was it
would have maybe more been akin to that
and since these books have
proliferations that just get weirder and
weirder as they go along
the idea that he could have continued
that on like a three book arc is like
you know whatever yeah then he got the
benefit of the doubt but then he also
did blade runner 40 20 49 which wasn't a
commercial hit but it definitely was a
critical one and he still
he's that director he was always like
doing smart stuff you think of something
like sicario
denny it wasn't that big of a jump it's
like scorsese doing gangster flicks and
then doing something more serious it's
like yeah you did start here but you
always had those sentiments does that
make sense yeah you could even look at
blade runner 2049 as by far the most
expensive demo reel ever made because if
you see that movie then you say this is
the guy that i want adapting dune and
the fact he's doing it in two parts so
alice i'll go back to you for the 2021
version what's the scene in that film
that really stands out to you that says
this is why this movie is where it is in
in my heart and also on the tomato meter
uh sort of car planet baby all day um
that when they go to the so there's this
army right that in the and they show up
in the lynch version and there's a lot
of things in the lynch version they're
just like he just kind of was like oh
yeah they're here like they don't really
get big a lot of people don't get big
entrances and a lot of characters don't
get huge entrances and like for instance
like the duncan character like that
lynch is like i don't know who this guy
is or why he's here he shows up he's
there i don't i forget what even sir you
know i i what even happens to him you
know it's not like the mamoa sort of
like the big sort of roll out that you
know that he gets
so the sardakar is like this army of
mercenaries and
in the denis version you get to see
where they come from and there's a sort
of there's a whole culture on their
planet uh you know there's the there's a
guy kind of like exhorting them to i
guess you know battle more effectively
in and he's got kind of throat singing
you know he's doing that thing where you
hit two pitches at once with your voice
he's got a whole microphone
situation and that was an example of
something that that's not in the uh the
the lynch version and it was like really
amazing to see that betrayed these
legions are the finest in the imperium
trained by gurney alec
duncan idaho
three battalions
has agreed
just the scope of the denny one and like
you know the giants the spaceships that
are like the size of a moon kind of
coming down like he really it's it's
very clear that unlike lynch who
there's a rumor that he never read the
book
lynch and that he just kind of got the
script and sort of was into it and said
sure and then worked on it with some
writers but that he never actually read
herbert like
denise is obviously a fan of this
obviously wants to go the distance and
make all of these crazy books which i
would love to just talk about for a
second in the context of these movies if
we can like where this franchise is
theoretically going if you've read the
novels but
so yeah i think that's you know it's
it's it's that moment for me it's it's
seeing things that were never uh
dramatized before um you know like then
that's that's what's what's most
exciting and i like when he uh when paul
has his little spice trip outside of the
uh the carry all in the sort of the big
you know the big the first sand worm
sequence when he kind of uh goes on his
you know
they make more of that in the denim
version it happens very quickly for
mclaughlin he's like oh spice like you
know but this is like you got timothy
definitely gets like the contact high
and sort of has the visions and
everything i like yeah you're up i'll
i'll take that ball and run with it
because that was clearly an example of
everyone by 2021 knowing what exactly
happens at joshua tree and needing a
little bit more of a feel for whoa this
is like i mean
dude is tripping balls outside and
there's a sand worm coming which is
again beetlejuice fan on him as soon as
i heard sand room i'm like oh i'm
totally in on this movie but the way
that the sand worms look where you get
to see the cloud and then you just get
to see just this massive
beast that lives below the surface that
first scene where we have to rescue
everyone and then
gurney has to run out and and grab paul
and get him back i also love love love
jaclyn the ships i love like the
butterfly helicoptery things those were
so cool looking you know it is just the
first part of this and so alex kind of
going back to what you were saying
before about where this is going at
least according to the novels
what are you most excited about or maybe
apprehensive about going into when we do
get to experience the next chapter in
dennyville news dune i mean
look if you know these novels or if you
don't i'm gonna i'm gonna say it without
spoiling too much
they cover their six books that herbert
wrote and they cover tens of thousands
of years of history because that's what
this story in the real sort of like when
you take a step back that's what it
turns out to be it turns out to be about
this like
millennia-long eugenics project because
basically certain people in this story
have figured out that there is only one
path uh that leads to uh
every other path leads to humanity's
extinction there's only one way for like
humans to survive into the tens of
thousands of years into the future and
so imagine basically if you have that
knowledge and you're the emperor of the
galaxy you rule the entire galaxy and
you have to let stuff happen and you
might have to sort of commit a little
genocide here and there because
ultimately it's going to lead to people
still being around and so there's all of
these like you know
really bleak and you know fascinating
and horrible you know decisions that
these characters are going to have to
make but like thinking about these
actors and the sort of the journey that
they are going to go on that like the
timothy's arc and then like who's
actually gonna be in the sixth one that
takes place millions and millions of
years after the first one like you could
not guess that from watching the first
movie and i kind of just don't i want to
talk about it but i don't want to talk
about it because i want to ruin it for
people i mean i think they should stop
i know where these stories go later it
just gets weirder like i really should
end in the first one before we get too
far along until people are fusing
i want lito the second man i want that
in a movie so much i just want to see
that happen and that's yeah i do i do i
really cause that just it gives me the
creeps in the best way it takes me this
is what i'm talking about like being
sort of like going back to being sort of
disturbed by this movie and having that
be
that's a deeper mark somehow if
something can sort of weird you out at
an age like it didn't give me nightmares
but i thought about it a lot
i mean yeah and then like you know i i
finally read these novels like i was way
too young to read those books and i
tried and it was just i don't this is
gonna be in latin but like i remember
reading those novels in like in my 30s
and just being like oh this is the most
incredible story and where it goes from
this initial sort of paula tradies kind
of space opera thing to
you know this wild psychedelic odyssey
across the galaxy i love the idea that
they're gonna keep giving denis this
like hundreds of millions of dollars
potentially to do this as long as these
people go like i've you know that's
that's the thing it's like i think i
feel about this the way that like marvel
people feel about oh i can't wait to see
this story be told on screen as it was
meant to be like i can't wait to see
them like whatever do the executioner's
song or something in the x-men movies
like that's how i feel about this that i
want i actually want the fan service of
these things being brought to life
because i actually feel like they have
the you know like we've been talking
about the beginning is they now have the
capability to do it at the scale
that will make it feel like it felt in
the books but also these will be the
weirdest blockbusters i'm so psyched for
that i'm so psyched for there to be
popcorn movies where a guy merges with
sand trout and is like look at me i have
i'm a worm with arms like it that's just
so like it doesn't it he said it ladies
and gentlemen he said it yeah i'm not
going to say who i mean it doesn't
matter let's put it
if they're really gonna come for you for
a spoiler let's get it i've been i've
been come forward for weirder things but
like look that's what that's what i'm
really stoked about with this that was
why i was really you know i'm rarely
like a like a you know a cheerleader for
a movie's success like i don't care
because obviously i love the 1984 dune
so clearly like i don't care about like
you know box office and that does not
factor in for me but i really was happy
that this movie did well because it
means that potentially we're going to
get these down the road and i don't know
if denise is going to spend the rest of
his life making dune films it might be
somebody else we might be in some kind
of like a roger moore version of dune by
the time we get to the san worms
merger stuff
but like god bless it i just really i'm
i'm stoked that it could potentially
happen
do we think that dune can continue to be
as successful as this first denny film
was because the movie made just under
400 million dollars worldwide and as
great as the critical and audience
perception was i'm just not sure that
you have a massive audience that might
want to come back and revisit this time
after time after time i hope i'm wrong
because i don't want everything to just
feel like a spider-man you know with now
we we're opening up multi-verses and
that kind of stuff i would love for this
trend to continue but
jacqueline you know people in high
places is this something that can
continue to have the legs that the first
one did um
yes yes it can it does there are
incredible moments to my point i'm i'm
just saying it does get more outlandish
i think there's things you're gonna have
to change
i do for believability like
i can't you can't make it a worm with
arms like you just can't
you know what i mean but there's maybe
ways to make it seem like he's fused
with the worm
you know like some you know the earlier
parts of jeff goldblum as the fly making
him look a little bit like i hate that
okay you know
they found a cool way to do baron
harkonnen too though i mean the the uh
like a sort of a more stylized way like
in the lynch version he's just a fat guy
covered in pustules like on wires
floating around the room and it's it's
gross and it's grotesque and horrifying
and he's like a nightmare creature who
would scare you as a kid but the stalin
scar scarred is much more it's like a
sleek kind of like he's rising out of
the water you don't see his full size
necessarily like you don't you know it's
he's much more of a like an ominous kind
of scary figure there's a cool way i
mean
denise is like a stylish director he'll
find a way to do the worm with arms that
gets maybe not you jacqueline but like
some people will buy in on the worm with
arms like i feel like that's gonna
i believe that that's going to happen oh
yeah you're talking to one of them right
now i'm i'm fully in on the worm with
arms
now i'll be disappointed if i don't get
a movie that features a worm with arms
let's do some some comparisons uh here
too because i mean again this is what i
do i like making art competitive if if i
give you one version
of dune and you have to take just the
1984 or the 2021 alex i'll start with
you which one do you take and do you
keep for all time
the 1984 version gave us
a plastic action figure of sting holding
a hairless cat in a terrarium and i kind
of have to give it to 84 based on that
and many other sentimental reasons but
that is spoken with you know no hate at
all for the uh the 2021 which is it's a
good tiebreaker is stinging a hairless
cat action figure plus i would take a
look hans zimmer is a is the maestro of
maestros i'm taking toto and brian nino
overhands zimmer jack what am i crazy
here
yes what have you all been on listen
okay
i will say this is the choice this is
the choice the choice is between
a complete
subpar movie
or an epic amazing movie that finishes
in the middle of itself
because like we didn't even talk about
this but the problem i have with diddy
venice dune is that it is a song that
finishes in the middle of it like it is
not a complete movie it is literally in
the middle of the story this is not lord
of the rings lord of the rings were
chapters with starts and finishes rising
actions and falling actions
and then you preview to the next chapter
but this is not bad this is just in the
middle of the song
turn around look at zendaya
fade to black this is not a movie it's
not a movie
it is an episode it is an epic episode
but it is an episode it is not a movie
and it's not even an episode i can't
even call it an episode it's literally
like a midi series that doesn't just end
like correctly it does not end correctly
but i would rather take an uncompleted
song that was played well than listening
to that tammany hall recital
that's i mean
alex i'll go back to you for the final
word on dune because i do want to talk
to you a little bit about the big hit
show real quick but if you're just to
encapsulate your your love of dune and
and let's stick with the 2021 version
here what is it about this that you're
just so excited that the world finally
gets to see um you know a lot of the
story points that you have known for so
long being a fan as long as you have
been i just think it is a completely
different type of story even though it's
about a young man with a very special
destiny which is the plot of star wars
the plot of harry potter it's a plot you
know it's it's one of the master plots
everything that goes on around that in
terms of the
politics
and religion
and ecology stuff that comes out of the
novel and changes the story uh is
something that we haven't really gotten
in one of these movies you know star
wars comes out in 77 it's very much
indebted to the novel so a lot of those
things like you know
make their way into the culture via star
wars but there is
stuff in the herbert version that
even if it's not even if it's only sort
of touched on uh just makes it a
different kind of story and makes it
basically you know it's a story about
it's it's te lawrence it's a story about
somebody who goes into the you know goes
into the desert and then leads an
uprising against you know his own people
in a way it's a really fascinating you
know it has all of these crazy political
parallels and i'm really interested to
see like where that
goes and i think that's you know that's
why i'm i'm most excited and i'm most
excited to see just how someone attempts
to pull off the
really weird disturbing hard sci-fi
stuff because i think what both of these
movies have in common
84 and 21 and what i like about both of
them is that
a real sort of future world and
authentic sci-fi world would be kind of
like a horror movie world to us we would
be weirded out there would be stuff
about it that would be just gross and
sort of like we would be uncomfortable
with like what is required of us you
just think about even the in both movies
the suits where you just pee all day and
it recycles your urine and everything
else and then you you drink that it's a
very basic sort of like gross horrifying
thing that's like totally normal in in
their world and i think that's what's
you know that's what's great about it is
that it's
it's an authentically and in some cases
disturbingly
built out fantasy world that is not like
our own and does not have the rules of
our own and does not have the ethics of
our own necessarily because it becomes
like i said it becomes about eugenics on
a multi-millennial scale which is a very
weird thing to talk about and it's an
extremely weird thing to think about who
the heroes or these movies are going to
be and what choices they're going to be
making and like how that's how that's
going to play out in a big like
blockbuster movie with like jason momoa
waving swords around in it like i want
to know i want to feel that and like i
don't know what that's going to be like
and that's very exciting to me because i
feel like a lot of these you know a lot
of these huge movies are very much about
like oh they did the thing like the
thing that i knew about from before they
finally put it on screen in a way that
looks like the thing that i read the
comic book or whatever it is and like
you know i don't know i'm always so uh
so happy to talk to people who have made
such a successful career in
podcasting and and one of the questions
i always love asking is
for you alex it's pretty on the nose
because your show is the big hit show
podcast when did you know it was it was
becoming this big hit when did you know
that you had something something special
that you were doing i have really
enjoyed i don't know i mean we've just
literally like we are tomorrow we were
recording this and like tomorrow's
wednesday and we are launching our
second string of uh five episodes so we
just did this thing uh we just did five
episodes on the twilight saga and the
next five episodes are about kendrick
lamar's two pimple butterfly and so
that's i mean right there that's the
thing that makes me really happy about
this show is that i think that we have
created something where like
we can do
a lot of different kinds of stories and
twi the twilight
season is like nothing like the kendrick
season in so many ways in terms of it's
still me hosting it but like the way
that it's
structured in the way that it makes its
arguments is completely different and
like you know obviously like all of the
you know all of the voices are different
and like all these different people so
i'm really excited because if you just
take big hits as your purview it limits
you obviously to things that have
succeeded in some way that have you
either been like commercially and or
critically culturally successful but you
there's so much within that uh that you
can do and there's so many different
places uh that it they can go to so i
think that's like you know i don't know
that that's an answer to your question
that's the thing that gets me most
excited about uh working on it and you
know continuing to work on it i just
have one question on
like just the forethought on these
because it does seem like you like to
your point that you're not bound to
anything is there anything that's
currently been requested that you
haven't gotten to yet but you feel like
okay like this is the this is the next
uh area like if i don't the fans are
gonna lose it a little bit is there one
that is more requested than others
no i'm waiting for some i'm waiting for
people to start requesting things
honestly i think like there's too much
uh trust in us people aren't like when
are you gonna do this
like i need to hear from from from y'all
from like from
jacqueline like what would you like us
to you know to dive into because there's
i mean you know it's me personally bill
hater and beyonce but that's just that's
for this audience of one i don't know i
don't know i don't i don't know what the
masses want but
uh they might want dune and it seems
like
it seems like you certainly know how to
talk about that at length so you know it
could we see dune having a future on the
big hit show very true i would love much
like twilight it's a good story because
there's a lot of different iterations
that it goes through we haven't talked
about joe darrowski's dune at all but
like that's a you know that's another
crazy what might have been kind of
scenario for this franchise and uh yeah
i think you've convinced me i think in
the course of this conversation that i
should be doing a dune podcast you know
or you know if i haven't already done
one today there you go could happen and
the first time i've ever heard twilight
and dune correlated in such an accurate
manner so and to our fans make sure you
uh you hit up alex and and look you can
trust him i trust him but if you have a
suggestion for the next you know episode
of uh or the next series i guess of the
big hit show let him know before we let
you go alex we always like to get a
streaming recommendation whether it's a
show a movie that you're currently kind
of obsessed with
as a parting gift so what is it out
there right now that you're checking out
that everybody else needs to get on
board with uh the last thing that i
watched that i thought was great was the
showtime documentary the individual list
which is about the street photographer
ricky powell
um he was a
sort of a party photographer nightlife
photographer in new york in the 80s he
shot for paper magazine he shot
everybody as they were coming up all
these young stars he's there's a famous
like have you ever seen the famous
picture of like lawrence fishburn when
he's like 25 or whatever he's got that
like denim jacket on he's like looking
over his shoulder there's a couple of
shots in this movie they're like oh i
didn't know that like the one person
took all these pictures and he was like
a sort of a downtown legend uh becomes
affiliated with a young rap group called
the beastie boys around the time of
licensed to ill becomes part of their
entourage tours with them like lives
among them like lives the high life with
the beastie boys and just like their you
know crazy party antics and all of this
and then as the beastie boys sort of
grow up and mature and maybe don't like
aren't spraying beer on each other so
much anymore
uh ricky is no longer
part of that lifestyle in the same way
and he kind of has to figure out what to
do with his life and you know if you're
me and you grew up listening to the
beastie boys and hearing ricky powell's
name in those songs and knowing who some
of these folks were and like you know
reading grand royal magazine and seeing
him in there and everything this is a
fascinating and ultimately kind of sad
look at
you know what that life is like like
what happens when you are picked up by
the hurricane of a famous band and then
kind of dropped back
into your life and you have to figure
out
what to do next with it and you know
ricky has some success and he has some
you know some failures and some sadness
but it was uh you know talking about
like revisiting sort of things from your
youth it was like oh that this is what
that guy's life was actually like that
you know that name so that's on um
that's like a showtime movie that any uh
what's it called again it's called the
individualist
i'm about this that's right well he is a
legend uh behind uh the the dune lore
and the explanation of all the great
stuff we got you can catch most
triumphant dropping april 28th and of
course check out the big hit show
wherever you digest your podcast alex
papademus it was an absolute pleasure
thank you so much for joining us please
come back soon anytime at all as long as
we can keep talking about dune
[Music]
thank you once again to alex papademis
uh make sure y'all check out the big hit
show podcast and we don't have a mailbag
today officially but but we're starting
to get a lot of y'all submissions for
hook the steven spielberg movie one of
the very few spielberg rotten movies and
so for instance tyler harper from
alberta canada sent us a great audio
recording of why tywer thinks that we
should do hook on the show so if you're
like taught you want us to talk about
hook send us a video or an audio
recording either one is fine same
address that you would send your mail to
where you think about the movie we
talked about our reaction to it rt is
wrong at rotten tomatoes
send us your audio and video as to why
we need to cover hook because we're
going to probably play tyler's in a
future episode along with a lot of y'all
submissions so that is rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com about the highly
controversial some love it some
including the guy talking right now
don't so much love hook subscribe rate
and review all the good things that your
podcast platform of choice tells you to
do do that for us here at rotten
tomatoes is wrong thanks again to alex
to my incredible co-host jacqueline
coley our amazing producer lucy brian
perez our expert engineer tim ryan our
review creation manager and everybody
here at rotten tomatoes i am merely mark
ellis saying we will see you
next time on rotten tomatoes is wrong
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you